well I think without question that if
you are running a multimedia company the
most important thing you can do is set
the editorial priorities and make sure
that you have people that you really
trust and believe in running different
departments and reporting to you of
course and you being completely involved
but you don't have to be on 24/7 and
nobody needs to be on 24/7 the media
operation is to be on 24/7 but not the
same people and that applies whether
you're running a media company whether
you're running an investment bank with
clients around the world this is the era
of collaboration we need to recognize
that if we work in teams then somebody
from the team will be on at all hours
but not the same person yes I found it
fascinating too but then truth is
paradoxical and one of the paradoxes is
that we are now increasingly using
technology to help us disconnect from
technology and reconnect with ourselves
and some of the most successful features
like the Apple feature do not disturb
or wearable devices that are related to
our growing recognition that we need to
learn to disconnect from technology in
order to actually nurture our humanity
our relationship with technology has led
to an enormous amount of behavioral
addictions and we need to treat them
seriously in our own lives for me it
starts with the first step which is
picking a time at the end of your day
preferably at least half an hour before
you're going to go to sleep when you
turn off all your devices and gently
escort them out of your bedroom this is
paramount as my nightstand is a
completely device free zone that has
spiritual books a candle a flower and
water so that before I go to sleep I can
really disconnect from my life and
recognize that there is another
dimension to Who I am beyond being the
editor of The Huffington Post or the
author of thrive or the mother of these
two children so a lot depends on
obviously where you're working there 35%
of American companies now midsize as
well as large that have introduced some
form of mindfulness into the workplace
that's a phenomenal amount of companies
and there is also a new listening in the
air I was talking to two young women
exactly at the stage you are describing
it was the first job at a company at
McKinsey actually and they decided to go
to their bosses and say to them that you
know we're going to work really hard get
everything done during the week but
we take our weekends off obviously there
is an emergency here is our cellphone
but were not an email that was a risk
right especially in companies which are
seen as the boiler room of burnout and
three months later their boss's boss
came to them and told them that they had
been identified as leaders in the
company because not only did they do a
great job but they had set boundaries
that had the guts to set boundaries for
themselves now I I'm pretty confident
that if that conversation had taken
place two three years ago the reaction
would not have been the same but now
this conversation that we are having
here is part of business magazines it's
part of the Harvard Business School and
the Stanford Business School so bosses
are not so surprised if they hear that
from new employees and provide they do a
good job talent is the hardest thing to
find at the moment and increasingly
companies are going to recognize that if
they're going to recruit and retain
talent they need to make sure that they
provide conditions which are humane
you